you  never meet your heroes well I did  and it was awesome  the Avengers were everything I imagined  hello San Francisco Thor Tony check it  out  at once try to keep up  this just got a whole lot more  interesting let's make this quick  secure the bridge those weapons they  can't get into the city are you set up  up down  door what's your status there are humans  trapped lots of small Angry Men with  Scottie is that a joke  the door make a joke  [Music]  Tony thorn the cables cap what's going  on over there  start to chimera what's your status  should head back no stay on task there's  [Music]  some say they were set up others call  them murderers do the Avengers pose a  danger to society that was the question  Bruce that was the question  well we all lost something that day but  that's not how this story ends  [Music]  well what are we waiting for  [Music]